nosotros ya sabemos que para esta celda
galvánica el zinc sólido se oxida hacia
el zinc 2 positivo verdad son iones de
5-2 positivo y la oxidación ocurre en
los ánodos verdad entonces este
electrodo que tenemos del lado izquierdo
es en realidad un ánodo este sería un
ánodo y por otro lado el cobre dos
positivos los iones de cobre 2 positivo
son reducidos hacia el cobre sólido
verdad y la reducción ocurre en el
cátodo así que el electrodo que tenemos
del lado derecho es el cátodo si
empezamos con una concentración 1 molar
de sulfato de zinc verdad eso significa
que en solución nuestra concentración
inicial de iones zinc 2 positivos sería
1 molar verdad y si también tenemos una
concentración 1 molar de sulfato de
cobre lo cual significa que empezamos
con una concentración de cobre 2
positivo 1 molar verdad entonces si
estamos bajo condiciones
digamos estándar nos encontramos a
concentraciones 1
verdad y también estamos a 25 grados
celsius y si con todo esto además
tenemos electrodos sólidos puros verdad
sabemos que los potenciales de es el de
estándar para este o el potencial de
celda bajo condiciones estándar para
esta para este caso es justamente 1.10
volts así que déjenme escribirlo tenemos
que el potencial de es el de estándar es
1.10 volts positivos cierto así que
tenemos una reacción redox espontánea
que produce una corriente los electrones
fluyen a través de este cable verdad y
obtenemos un voltaje tenemos un
potencial de celda estándar y en uno de
los videos en electroquímica verdad
tomamos digamos el potencial de es el de
estándar
y de ahí calculamos delta g cero verdad
y utilizamos esta ecuación verdad
utilizamos que delta
pero se puede calcular como menos ene
efe es 0 verdad donde en es el número de
moles
efe es la constante de faraday y es 0 es
justamente lo que teníamos aquí abajo
verdad que era 1.10 volts y en dicho
vídeo nosotros encontramos que este
delta g 0 era menos 212 kilos jules así
que fijémonos en la ecuación para el
cambio en la energía libre de la
termodinámica verdad y vamos a analizar
nuestra celda galvánica así que el
cambio en la energía libre es igual el
cambio en la energía libre es igual al
cambio en la energía libre bajo
condiciones estándar más r que es la
constante de los gases por t que es la
temperatura por el logaritmo natural de
q donde q es el cociente de reacción
recordemos brevemente esta es la
diferencia instantánea en la energía
libre entre los reactivos y los
productos del traje 0 es el cambio en la
energía libre bajo condiciones estándar
es la constante de los gases t es la
temperatura por supuesto esto debe ser
en kelvin y q es el cociente de reacción
así que pensemos primero qué pasa con el
cociente de reacción verdad para esta
reacción nuestra reacción redux
espontánea en este caso q tiene la forma
de la constante de equilibrio cierto
entonces aquí q lo podemos simplemente
expresar como la concentración de
productos entre la concentración de los
reactivos verdad y nosotros dejamos
fuera digamos no consideramos los
sonidos puros así que esto sería la
concentración del zinc 2 positivo verdad
estamos pensando en este de aquí los
iones de 5-2 positivo dividido entre los
iones de cobre 2 positivos es decir
estamos considerando la concentración de
los productos y dejamos los sólidos
fuera y dividimos entre la concentración
de los reactivos dejando los sólidos
fuera muy bien si nosotros introducir
las concentraciones que tenemos nosotros
tenemos una concentración 1 molar de 52
positivo y 1 molar de cobre 2 positivo
así que tenemos 1.0 dividido entre 1.0 y
eso nos da 1 así que esto lo podemos
digamos colocar en esta expresión que
tenemos arriba y vamos a obtener un
resultado verdad de hecho podemos ver
que si q es igual a 1 el logaritmo
natural de 1 es 0 y si 0 lo
multiplicamos por estos dos números en
realidad nos sigue dando 0 y podemos
concluir entonces que el cambio en la
energía libre verdad será igual al
cambio en la energía libre bajo
condiciones estándar lo cual es bastante
intuitivo y que de hecho ya sabíamos
cuánto era verdadera menos 212 kilos así
que voy a escribir esto el cambio en la
energía libre es igual al cambio en la
energía libre bajo condiciones estándar
y esto es menos 212 kilo
jules y por supuesto podríamos pensar
que estos son kilo jules
de la reacción muy bien entonces vamos a
dejarlo simplemente así verdad podemos
notar que la delta g tiene un valor
negativo así que podemos concluir que
esta reacción es espontánea verdad
sabemos que si el cambio en la energía
libre es negativo entonces la reacciones
espontáneas y que la corriente fluye a
través del cable y obtenemos un voltaje
ahora vamos a regresar un poquito arriba
verdad nosotros obtenemos un voltaje así
que de hecho nuestra reacción va hacia
la dirección de la derecha verdad para
crear más productos de hecho vamos a
hacer más productos de este lado verdad
vamos a hacer muchos más productos y si
nos preguntamos qué ocurre con q a
medida que la reacción procede hacia la
derecha bueno pues podemos ver que
estamos incrementando la concentración
de nuestros productos verdad en
particular estamos aumentando la
concentración del zinc dos positivos
verdad estamos aumentando la
concentración de los iones
los positivos por otro lado estaríamos
disminuyendo la concentración de los
reactivos en este caso por ejemplo
pensemos en la concentración de los
iones de cobre 2 positivo estamos
disminuyendo la concentración de los
iones de cobre 2 positivos si nos
fijamos que estamos aumentando los
productos y disminuyendo los reactivos
entonces podemos concluir que está
aumentando verdad que está aumentando
pero también podríamos preguntarnos si q
aumenta como cambiarla del tanque verdad
así que qué es lo que ocurre con la
diferencia instantánea en la energía
libre entre los reactivos y los
productos vamos a ver vamos a abonar
todo esto en nuestras ecuaciones verdad
digamos que nuestro cambio en cubahora
sube a un valor de puede ser digamos de
10.000 vamos a tomar un valor de 10.000
para el aumento de cv y notemos que
originalmente teníamos un valor de 1 muy
bien así que vamos a ir sustituyendo
todo esto
vamos a tener que el cambio o la
diferencia instantánea en la energía
libre será delta g 0 que ya sabíamos que
era menos 212 voy a ponerlo menos 212
mil y jules jules por supuesto y esto
podríamos pensarlo nuevamente como jules
por mol de reacción verdad más para más
vamos ahora a tomar la constante r que
nosotros sabemos que es 8.3 14 jules por
mol de la reacción por kelvin muy bien y
luego multiplicamos por la temperatura
la temperatura en este caso son 25
grados celsius que eso corresponde a 298
que el bien entonces tendremos 298 que
elvin aquí podemos ver que estos estás
digamos estas unidades se cancelan y
luego hay que multiplicar por el
logaritmo natural de q que en este caso
estamos considerando que es 10
así que si queremos calcular delta g
digamos para este momento entonces
tenemos que calcular el logaritmo
natural de 10.000 que el logaritmo
natural de 10.000 y eso hay que
multiplicarlo por 298 y multiplicarlo
por 8.3 14 muy bien 8.3 14 eso nos da
este resultado y luego hay que sumarle
menos 212 mil 212 mil muy bien y
obtenemos como resultado menos 189 mil
180 que lo podemos dejar simplemente
como menos 189.2 kilo jules por mol de
reacción verdad entonces obtenemos menos
déjenme bajar un poco que el cambio en
la energía libre será menos 189.2 kilo
jules por mol
muy bien así que en realidad no estoy
muy concentrado en digamos cuál es el
número exacto simplemente quiero hacer
notar qué es lo que ocurre a medida que
cambiamos como verdad a medida que hemos
incrementado que fuimos desde q igual a
1 hasta 10.000 y podemos ver que fuimos
de menos 212 kilos jules para el cambio
en la energía libre al valor de menos
189.2 kilo jules así que estamos
acercándonos un poco más a 0 verdad
estamos acercándonos al equilibrio pero
en este instante verdad justo cuando q
es igual a 10.000 aún tenemos un valor
negativo así que como tenemos un valor
negativo para delta que la reacción
sigue siendo espontánea la reacción
la reacción aún es espontánea muy bien
todavía es espontánea ok
así que aún vamos a generar una correa
corriente y vamos a generar todavía más
productos y vamos a tener un voltaje en
este momento del tiempo verdad cuál
sería el voltaje en este momento bueno
tendríamos que calcular el potencial de
zelda instantáneo verdad y el potencial
de zelda instantáneo sería lo que
tenemos que calcular y eso lo podemos
calcular a partir de la fórmula que
tenemos para delta g de verdad
delta g es igual a menos ene efe donde n
es el número de moles
efe es igual a la constante de faraday y
es justamente el potencial de zelda
instantáneo y simplemente para
ahorrarnos tiempo voy a darte de una vez
la respuesta puedes hacerlo en la
calculadora pero el potencial de celda
en este momento sería 0.98 volts muy
bien así que la reacción es espontánea
aún producimos
un voltaje verdad pero no tenemos que
nuestro voltaje ha disminuido muy poco
verdad en el ejemplo anterior bajo
condiciones estándar en este momento el
voltaje sería de 1.10 volts lo teníamos
por aquí verdad era de 1.10 volts y
ahora tenemos simplemente 0.98 que es
bastante parecido verdad ahora vamos a
preguntarnos qué ocurre en el equilibrio
así que sabemos que en el equilibrio
verdad el valor de q es igual a calp
cierto en este caso q es igual a la
constante de equilibrio verdad ya 25
grados celsius k es igual a 1.58 por 10
a la 37 muy bien eso es para esta
reacción a 25 grados celsius muy bien y
este es el valor de la constante de
equilibrio vamos a tomar este valor y
vamos a colocarlo en la ecuación para
delta g y veamos qué es lo que obtenemos
muy bien recordemos que
delta g sería menos 212 kilos
jules por mol muy bien más
vamos a ver lo de acá arriba muy bien
y aquí está la verdad r por t por el
logaritmo natural de q en este caso
recordemos que r era de 8.3 14 verdad
luego multiplicamos por la temperatura
que eran 298 kelvin y luego
multiplicamos por el logaritmo natural
de 1.58 por 10 a la 37 muy bien vamos a
hacer esto en la calculadora nuevamente
vamos a calcular el logaritmo natural de
1.58 por 10 a la 37 muy bien y luego eso
lo multiplicamos por 298 y multiplicamos
por 8.314 muy bien entonces si
redondeamos esto nos da 212 verdad eso
nos dará 212 212 por supuesto estos son
kilo jules por mol de reacción y aquí
tendremos menos 212 kilos recordemos en
realidad no nos estamos fijando en los
valores exactos
los modos este número que teníamos aquí
ya lo habíamos este redondeado el punto
es que cuando estamos en condiciones de
equilibrio verdad estos dos números se
cancelan y lo que obtenemos para cuando
estamos en equilibrio es que el cambio
en la energía libre es decir delta que
vale cero verdad ahora si nos fijamos en
esto veamos cuánto vale el potencial de
celda nosotros sabemos que el potencial
de celdas de hecho lo podemos calcular
de aquí se relaciona con la energía
libre con esta ecuación si este valor es
cero entonces este número que es el
potencial de celda también tiene que ser
cero verdad y tiene que ser cero y por
supuesto el voltaje cero cuando nuestra
reacción redox llega al equilibrio así
que la digamos la celda muere en la
batería ya no funciona verdad entonces
espero que esto te haya ayudado a
entender un poco más las celdas
galvánicas en términos de los cambios de
la energía libre